he visto muchos errores cuando los
estudiantes tratan de dibujar
estructuras resonantes así que quise
hacer un vídeo de los errores más
comunes que he visto así que digamos que
quiero dibujar una estructura resonante
para este carbó catión muy bien entonces
algunos estudiantes a lo mejor tomarían
estos electrones que estoy marcando
estos electrones que estoy marcando en
azul y los moverían hacia acá verdad es
lo que a lo mejor algunos harían muy
bien entonces ya la derecha ponemos lo
que quedaría como dibujo de esta
supuesta estructura resonante que en
realidad no es correcta nos quedaría
exactamente
de esta forma muy bien
sin embargo esta supuesta estructura
resonante es incorrecta verdad esta no
es una correcta no es una estructura
resonante correcta y la razón de por qué
no es correcta lo podemos observar
dibujando los hidrógenos que van en la
estructura original veamos aquí tenemos
tres enlaces eso quiere decir que aquí
hay un hidrógeno aquí tenemos otros tres
enlaces lo cual nos dice que hay otro
hidrógeno aquí hay dos enlaces lo cual
nos dice que hay dos hidrógenos y aquí
tenemos una carga positiva quiere decir
que aquí sólo hay un hidrógeno verdad
entonces fijémonos justamente en este
carbono de aquí entonces en este carbono
de aquí si nos fijamos bueno podríamos
simplemente copiar todos los hidrógenos
verdad podemos poner todos los hidro
genos como estaban previamente y nos
fijamos en el carbono que acabo de
marcar con rojo este carbono que acabo
de marcar tiene cinco enlaces aquí
tenemos uno
tres cuatro y cinco enlaces tenemos
cinco enlaces con el carbono esos son 10
electrones y eso no puede pasar verdad
debido a a la posición que tiene el
carbono en la tabla periódica que de
hecho se encuentra en el segundo periodo
verdad por estar en el segundo periodo
sólo hay cuatro orbitales que pueden
tener dos electrones cada uno por lo
tanto no puede exceder de ocho
electrones y aquí tendría diez verdad
otra cosa por la cual digamos podría
estar incorrecto es porque este de
electrón que tenemos aquí tiene solo
tres enlaces tiene unos 23 enlaces y eso
nos daría una carga formal extra verdad
entonces esta estructura resonante no es
correcta ok vamos ahora a dibujar la
estructura resonante correcta en
realidad estos electrones que tenemos
aquí deberían pasar hacia este sitio
para formar un doble enlace verdad vamos
a ver qué es lo que ocurre vamos a
dibujarlo digamos el estructura
de correcta tendríamos nuestro ciclo de
carbonos y ahora estos digamos estos
electrones que habíamos marcado en azul
ahora se encuentran de este lado verdad
quizás aquí habría hecho falta marcar
estos que en realidad se convierten en
este enlace doble pero bueno de eso se
trata y ahora vamos a ver dónde se
encuentra la carga positiva en realidad
ahora la carga positiva se encuentra de
este lado y es más fácil ver cuando
dibujamos los hidrógenos verdad en
realidad por ejemplo acá teníamos un
hidrógeno verdad simplemente estoy
copiando los hidrógenos que teníamos
arriba y aquí teníamos solo un hidrógeno
entonces este carbono que tenemos de
este lado que estoy marcando con rojo
ahora tiene cuatro enlaces lo cual
quiere decir que su carga formal es nula
sin embargo en el carbono que tenemos
aquí teníamos solo un hidrógeno y ahora
tenemos tres enlaces lo cual quiere
decir que
este carbono que estoy marcando con rojo
tiene una carga formal positiva entonces
como puedes darte cuenta esto se empieza
a volver muy engorrosos y dibujamos
todos los hidrógenos en realidad la
estructura resonante sin estar dibujando
los hidrógenos se vería algo
y así verdad y tenemos un doble enlace
acá ok y por supuesto le hace falta su
carga positiva entonces una vez que ya
hemos entendido qué es lo que está
pasando ya no es necesario dibujar los
hidrógenos los hidrógenos sólo hacen que
las estructuras se vuelvan confusas y
quizás hasta difíciles de entender muy
bien ahora vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo aquí tenemos
esta nueva molécula ok y vamos a empezar
justo como en el ejemplo anterior vamos
a empezar primero dibujando una forma
incorrecta muy bien entonces a lo mejor
un estudiante podría decir que si tiene
una carga formal negativa en este
nitrógeno puede tomar una pareja de
electrones digamos que puede tomar esta
pareja de electrones y empujar estos
electrones hacia este sitio para formar
un doble enlace lo cual obliga a este
otro doble lado bueno a este enlace
extra que tenemos a moverse a este sitio
entonces cómo es que quedaría esta
estructura no tendríamos aquí nuestro
nitrógeno tendríamos los enlaces del
ciclo verdad y ahora tendríamos solo una
pareja de electrones ya que el otro
ahora forma un enlace doble con el
carbono que se encuentra de este lado y
ahora el enlace doble que teníamos aquí
se encuentra por acá es más vamos a
vamos a hacer un rastreo digamos de los
electrones usando colores estos
electrones que se encontraban en el
nitrógeno ahora están en este enlace
doble
ahora fijémonos por ejemplo en el enlace
que teníamos no sé vamos a hacerlo con
azul claro este enlace que teníamos aquí
ahora se encuentra de este lado y por
supuesto los electrones restantes del
nitrógeno se quedan
junto al nitrógeno así que nuevamente
podríamos preguntarnos bueno porque esta
no es una estructura válida y nuevamente
es muchísimo más claro si vemos esto
dibujando los hidrógenos por ejemplo
aquí tenemos solo un hidrógeno ya que
hay tres enlaces aquí también tenemos un
hidrógeno porque ya hay tres enlaces y
aquí tenemos dos hidrógenos ya que hay
dos enlaces eso quiere decir que aquí
también habrá dos hidrógenos y quizás ya
es muy claro para ti porque está mal y
aquí había uno y acá también hay un
hidrógeno entonces si nos fijamos en
este carbono tenemos exactamente uno dos
tres cuatro cinco enlaces nuevamente son
cinco enlaces lo cual significa que hay
10 electrones lo cual nos dice que esta
posible estructura resonante no es
correcta verdad
vamos a ver entonces cuál sería la
estructura resonante correcta esta
pareja de electrones solitarios que
tenemos en el nitrógeno sí es cierto que
pasan digamos estos dos electrones y es
cierto que pasan a este enlace de aquí
para formar un enlace doble ok sin
embargo lo que está mal es que este
enlace que tenemos aquí bueno este
enlace doble uno de ellos pasa a formar
una pareja de electrones solitarios en
el carbono verdad entonces si nosotros
llevamos cuenta de este enlace
digamos con azul claro y solo para
guardar el código de colores teníamos
que esta pareja era magenta entonces
cuál sería el dibujo de la estructura
resonante correcta aquí tenemos nuestro
nitrógeno muy bien tenemos nuestro ciclo
y ahora estos electrones que teníamos en
azul oscuro forman un enlace doble con
este carbono que se encuentra aquí
el enlace que tenemos marcado con azul
claro ahora son los electrones
solitarios que se encuentran en el
carbono verdad y por supuesto los dos
restantes que quedaban en el nitrógeno
pues ahí se quedan si analizamos qué es
lo que ocurre con las cargas en realidad
aquí el nitrógeno pues ahora ya tiene
una carga neutra verdad una carga formal
neutra mientras que aquí tenemos un
carbono que tiene una carga formal
negativa esto es mucho más claro
nuevamente si ponemos los hidrógenos en
realidad si si recordamos este carbono
sólo tenía un hidrógeno verdad sólo
tenía un hidrógeno unido a él y es ahí
cuando pasamos a esta estructura
resonante debería marcar de nuevo estos
electrones aquí sólo tenemos tres
enlaces verdad
tres enlaces y una pareja de electrones
solitario es lo cual quiere decir que
obtenemos una carga negativa verdad
nuevamente si dibujamos ya sin tantos
hidrógenos y sin tanta digamos maraña
aquí que tenemos en realidad nos queda
la siguiente estructura tenemos nuestro
nitrógeno con su pareja de electrones
solitarios nuestra estructura cíclica un
enlace doble entre el nitrógeno y el
carbono y en este carbono tenemos una
pareja de electrones solitarios dándonos
una carga formal negativa muy bien así
que si tienes problemas dibujando
estructuras resonantes probablemente es
porque no estás considerando los
hidrógenos cuando los pones es mucho más
fácil ver si tu estructura resonante es
correcta ahora todo esto se trata de
práctica así que mientras más
estructuras dibujes tendrás una mejor
habilidad para hacerlo si te equivocas
no es ningún problema solo aprende del
error y sigue practicando